stop before video begins i want to send
some love
to today's sponsor nordvpn when i was in
italy i tried to stream but my internet
was so bad it barely functioned so they
graciously sent me a
startling which worked amazingly and
finally i had internet long story short
love nordvpn everyone should use a vpn
let me explain to you why if you're
browsing on someone else's wi-fi or
network which i know you do all the time
you need to use a vpn to protect
yourself and your data your isp can see
everything that you're doing everything
they can see everything unless you use
norvpn of course norvpn has a strict no
logs policy you don't have to worry
about any of that it's super easy to use
on your phone or your computer bada bing
bada boom you're in one click it's super
fast
i personally been loving using nordvpn
recently because i've been showing might
say these old swedish tv shows that
obviously you have to be in sweden to
watch bada bing bada boom vpn one click
and i'm in
i'm in sweden watching mysterious pokede
and if you sign up using the link in
description make sure you use the link
there's no code nordvpn.com pewdiepie
and that way you get a huge discount on
a two-year plan plus one additional free
month
you're welcome they also have a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if you're not
sure about a vpn or how it works or what
the purpose is you can try it out for
free for 30 days and get your money back
100 guarantee uh they've just been a
great sponsor and i'm very happy with
them so it's a great service it's a
win-win check it out on with the video
youtube is being dumb again what else is
new
good evening everyone my poppy smart
reply
[Music]
recently a youtuber named totally not
mark had over 150 of his videos deleted
due to the japanese company touhou
toy animation they own the rights to cut
anime like one piece dragon ball sailor
moon a big shot company that basically
couldn't care less
about some random anime youtuber let's
get real here i'll link to totally not
mark in the description check him out go
give him support i actually have some
personal issue with the
as well that i want to bring up at the
end of this video but keeping toy
animation in mind japan especially is so
notoriously
dumb when it comes to copyright
backwards thinking or or uh just overall
lacking in what most people agree with
what is fair use and not they just don't
care they're a big company that's it you
probably remember as well with japan and
nintendo having the youtube creator
program if you want to give us free
promotion with let's plays
you have to go through us okay which
everyone said that was a stupid as hell
idea and lo and behold it was shut down
they're just blatantly behind and i
think it's important that we call these
things out so that hopefully they can
listen this what happened to mark just
really highlights a huge issue with
youtube is that any day your your
livelihood on youtube could get removed
because some big company decided out of
the blue
that
no
stop thing i watch mark's videos just to
get an idea sort of you know is it fair
use is it not and you know he does rely
heavily on clips from the shows
themselves but as far as i understand
with copyright laws that you are allowed
to show clips as in form and reference
and mark's point in this video is that
even if he does counterclaim these
videos youtube's system is so slow that
he would literally i think he did the
math it will take 68 years or something
or he'll be 68 by the time he's
reclaimed all his videos
it's just completely pointless to even
try and fight it so i mean what else can
you do it just shows that youtube is
always in favor of the company when it
comes to copyright you know basically
how it goes if you get a copyright claim
is as
a company goes and say hey that that
video that's mine now and you go no
actually that's fair use i i follow all
the guidelines i've carefully crafted
this content and then their response is
basically nah
i still want it and youtube goes yeah
yeah he's right
that's how it works
and youtube knows how big of an issue
this is they revealed millions of
incorrect copyright claims in just six
months it's such a splurge of copyright
issue where youtube doesn't want to deal
with it so they give companies these
tools to take down and make it as easy
for them as possible but without any
regard for us as creators of what we can
do about it to play devil's advocate
just for a minute youtube has become
massively improved when it comes in
favor of of the copyright for the
creators to be fair because there didn't
used to be anything that we could do if
a video got claimed back in the day it's
like ah what can you do it's gone now
hey
that's still pretty much the case but
it's still better because now at least
you can get the option to hey do you
want to trim out the segment which is
still a painfully slow process because
if you get like two clips you have to
wait for one to get finished and then go
back to another one which yeah it's
small i'm just nitpicking but or you can
mute the song or replace a song i don't
know if you ever watched a video where
the song has been replaced it just goes
from hey guys so i just wanna
[Music]
it's just it's it's awful it's awful i
mean practically my entire library from
2016 and backwards it's it's just gone
it's gonna take too long to deal with it
i whatever take it take my money i don't
care
so in this article posted by the verge
about how much incorrect copyright
claims are occurring i really got very
pissed off to be honest reading about
ah here it is when users dispute these
claims the case result in favor of the
uploader of the video 60
of the time according to the report so
they're kind of saying
the majority still goes to the creator
look 60 of the time it favors you guys
listen if i
accuse everyone
in the whole world of stealing from me
and sixty percent of them comes back and
me and can and can prove that i'm wrong
that doesn't mean i'm 40 right that just
still means i'm 100 wrong that doesn't
favor other people it still favors me
massively it's blatant theft a lot of
the times too and i've had this problem
too uh recently where all my music got
claimed i don't know if you noticed this
but if you go to [ __ ] lasagna you can
see that it's been claimed by a company
called repos network and then princesses
on behalf of pewdiepie nah what do you
[ __ ] you can't just say it's on
behalf of me that's not just stealing
that's stealing and lying about it i
know i didn't claim that i didn't tell
anyone to do that and the thing is like
i even put in the description feel free
to use this track it won't be claimed
like i want people to oh god it pisses
me off i wanted people to like remix and
do fun stuff with the song because i
don't support this whole claim music
thing i think it's completely backwards
look at tik tok how many songs are
blowing up purely because kids are using
it as a reference in a clip or whatever
it is a positive but companies aren't
seeing it whatever that's their issue
but it's even so bad that some [ __ ] i
don't know i don't know how this was
possible that someone can claim my own
video and say it's me how is that
possible youtube like i deliberately
didn't go with a label with any of my
music because i hate how they run stuff
on youtube and it's it still [ __ ] me so
bad and the thing is like you know fine
i understand it's a difficult process to
run copyright on youtube it's never
going to be perfect but the kind of
stuff that happened to totally not mark
where he literally has no chance of
rectifying the situation or or make his
own case
it's not okay and even the
this video you know that was claimed by
me apparently like i said i don't expect
everything to be perfect but if i
counter claim a bogus claim you'd think
that youtube would
say yeah that is a bogus claim they re
they rejected my dispute youtube is
favoring with the the company
so i now have the choice to replace a
song or mute the song
cool i can't use my own music in my own
videos anymore that's awesome the [ __ ]
is this but uh you know 60 is in the
favor of the creator guys so there's
really no reason to freak out there's no
reason to be pissed off at all anyway
i'm uh i'm glad that this is getting
highlighted uh i hope there's some
silver lining of some some change
actually happening here because this is
just not okay subscribe and you can win
a billion poppy gloria out